Biden cannot be the nominee so we had
that election uh several elections the
other day Democrats did pretty well
people are freaking out there like fire
Ron McDaniel Democrats are freaking out
too they were like this doesn't mean
anything good for Biden in fact it shows
that what Jonathan Chate argued is the
Democrats actually could win this but
Biden will tank the Democrats if he's on
the ticket they're going to replace him
100% I've been saying it for two years
though replac him with Gavin Newsome
he's already running a shadow campaign
right now no it's why he named that lady
to the senate seat in California because
she was the head of Emily's List which
is one of their best activist arms on
the left that secured the promise that
they will support him becoming the new
nominee I guarantee it he's going to be
the guy every and they are correct about
that Biden is much weaker than the other
Democrats